لقد حصلت على هذا التقرير الذي لم يسبق له مثيل
من قبل ديفيد لوكريدج،
موظف Ocean Gate المطرود، وهو يعرض تفاصيل
العديد من المشكلات التي وجدها مع الغواصة
أثناء التفتيش، أخبرنا المزيد عما
وجده في هذا التقرير
بالتأكيد نعم ربما كان ديفيد لوكريدج هو
الوحيد  طيار غواصة ذو خبرة عالية
عمل في Ocean Gate في ذلك
الوقت وتم تعيينه كمدير
للعمليات البحرية وكجزء من هذا
الدور أثناء انتقالهم من
مرحلة البناء إلى مرحلة الاختبار،
كان مطلوبًا منه التوقيع على أن هذا
آمن  لذلك كان يثير المخاوف
على أرضية المصنع خلال معظم
النصف الأخير من عام 2017 وكان
يتم فصله باستمرار عند هذه النقطة
قرر أنه سيأخذ
تقرير التفتيش الجاد هذا
وسيقوم بتفصيل كل شيء
كتابيًا و  أرسله كتابيًا إلى
ستوكتون راش الرئيس التنفيذي وتوني نيسن
مدير الهندسة، وفي هذا
أه خلال اليوم التالي كان يوم
18 يناير 2018، لذا منذ أكثر من خمس
سنوات، قامت شركة لوكبريدج بفحص
كل مكون رئيسي في الغواصة
ووجدت  كان هذا الغراء يخرج من
مشاهد أكياس الصابورة التي كانت لديك
مسامير تثبيت تهدد بتمزيق
الأشياء، وجوه السقف التي بها
فتحات غطس آرون، وأخاديد دائرية
انحرفت عن المعلمات القياسية،
كل ما يمكن أن يحدث بشكل خاطئ كان نوعًا من
الخطأ، كانت هناك
مخاطر تمزق  لقد كانت مكونات مهمة
متصلة
بروابط مضغوطة وأرضيات قابلة للاشتعال والغلاف الداخلي من الفينيل
ينبعث منه غازات شديدة السمية
عند الاشتعال، لكن القلق الأول
بالنسبة إلى لوكريدج كان أن النواة الفعلية
لهذه الغواصة هي حدود الضغط
التي تبقي الناس على قيد الحياة عند
3800 درجة مئوية.  متر حيث يوجد تيتانيك حيث يبلغ
ضغط الماء الخارجي حوالي ستة
آلاف رطل لكل بوصة مربعة. مصنوع
من ألياف الكربون التي لا تستخدم في
الغواصات في أعماق المحيطات لأنها تحت
الضغط تكون مادة متقلبة
ولم يتم تصنيعها لاستخدامها تحت
الضغط، إنها ألياف  مثل الحبل،
فهو قوي تحت التوتر ولكن ليس
تحت الضغط، لذلك قام بفحص هذا
الجزء منه ووجد أنه
مملوء بثقوب صغيرة، كما تعلم، كان
يحمل ثقوبًا صغيرة وكان
يفصل هذه الطبقات، كان برج الثور
وكان يحمل ضوءًا خلفه  ووجدت أن
الضوء كان يتدفق من خلاله
ورفض التوقيع على الغوص
وقال ستوكتون راش إنه بسبب
رفضك التوقيع على اختبار هذا الرجل،
لا يمكنك القيام بعملك
كمدير للعمليات البحرية ولذلك قام
بطرده على  اكتشف نعم بطريقة
كان يؤدي بها عمل بن وتم
فصله بسبب قيامه بعمله وعليك أن
تتساءل عما كان سيحدث لو
كان قادرًا على القيام بعمله بالفعل، لذلك
لديك في هذا أه أنت أيضًا تشارك الاهتمام
في الحالات التي يبدو فيها أن راش يسيء
إلى النقد بشكل شخصي
لأن لوكريدج يعرف أشخاصًا
خارج Ocean Gate وهناك رئيس مشارك
لشركة لديها بالفعل
غواصة مصنفة من التيتانيوم بالطبع، هذه
الغواصة التي انفجرت لم تكن
مصنفة  ويقول له هذا الرئيس المشارك لهذه الشركة إنه
يحذره بشكل أساسي
وينتقد ستوكتون راش قائلاً
إنه سئم من اللاعبين في الصناعة الذين
يحاولون استخدام حجة السلامة لوقف
الابتكار، وبدا واثقًا جدًا من أنه
كان يفعل شيئًا جديدًا ومختلفًا
وأنه تم إحباطه من قبل الناس الذين
قالوا إن ذلك باسم السلامة، لكنه
بدا مقتنعًا بأنه لم يكن كذلك على الرغم من أنه من
الواضح حقًا أنه كان
نعم، في نهاية اليوم تعود هذه المأساة
إلى أه الغطرسة، لقد كانت مسألة
هذا الأمر  تعلمون نوعًا ما سلوك وادي السيليكون
المدمر، لكن الأمر لم يكن يتعلق
بالتغلب على الشركات الأخرى، بل كان يتعلق
بمحاولة التغلب على الفيزياء ولن
تفوز بذلك ولم يفوزوا
بذلك وكان الأمر واضحًا تمامًا
بالنسبة لـ  سنوات
لم يتم فيها بناء هذه الغواصة بطريقة
تعمل تحت ضغط كبير، يمكنك
بناء غواصة تجريبية ولكن
لا يمكنك استيعاب الركاب فيها، وهو أمر
غير قانوني تمامًا، ولذلك قاموا
بتنظيم الشركة بحيث
تقع خارج الولايات المتحدة.  لقد
تم اتخاذ جميع أنواع
الخطوات بحيث لم يكونوا في
الواقع ركابًا، وتم
تصنيفهم على أنهم متخصصون في المهمة ولكن
كيف يمكن أن يكون لديك طفل يبلغ من العمر 19 عامًا
يخشى الذهاب إلى
التخصص، إنه أمر غير متماسك تمامًا
وأتخيل ذلك  ستعرف أن
هذا سيستمر لفترة طويلة في
المحاكم لأنه لا يمكنك وصف
شيء ما بأنه حادث إلا إذا كان
حادثًا حقًا وإذا كان هناك خمس سنوات من
التحذيرات الصريحة للغاية من المهندسين
التي تشرح هذه هي الطريقة التي سينفجر بها
الأمر وأنت ترفض ذلك  لأخذهم على
محمل الجد، يجب أن نصل إلى نقطة
يتحمل فيها شخص ما المسؤولية عن ذلك الذي قام به
ديف لوكريدج من جانبه
بعد أن تم تعيينه، ما هو الدرس
هنا في الفصل الدراسي لأنه كان
ممتلئًا جدًا براش المقاوم للحصول على
فصله الغاطس ومع ذلك ما هو  من
الواضح جدًا في تقريرك مدى أهمية
هذه العملية في توفير
غواصة آمنة للناس
للذهاب إلى هذه الأعماق،
نعم 3800 متر ليس في الواقع، كما تعلم،
إنه في عمق شديد لنكن
واضحين، لكنه لم يكن شيئًا غير مسبوق مما
كان يفعله  كان كسر الحدود، وكان
كسر جزء من هذه العملية
هو محاولة القيام بذلك في غواصة
غير مصنفة ومن الواضح أنها مصممة للقيام
بما فعلته وهو الفشل في
الغواصات التي يمكن أن
تذهب إلى تيتانيك منذ الثمانينيات.
أه أحد الأشخاص المذكورين في مقالتي
كان يقود جولات إلى سفينة تايتانيك في
منتصف العقد الأول من القرن الحادي والعشرين باستخدام الغواصات السوفيتية التي
تم بناؤها في الثمانينات وآخرون في
المقالة أه لأنني صادف أنني كنت في
البحر معهم منذ عدة سنوات لأكثر من ذلك
بكثير  نوع من المغامرة الجادة حيث كانوا
يرسلون رجلاً غواصة تم
تصنيفها إلى أعمق نقطة في كل
محيط، وأعمق نقطة في
المحيط الهادئ هي 11000 متر، وهي ثلاثة أضعاف
عمق تيتانيك، ولهذا الغواصة
أخذوا الرجل من
وكالة التصنيف  إلى أسفل
خندق ماريانا وقع على أن العمق غير محدود
على عمق 11000 متر.